cyberpunk 2077 has had a less than ideal
launch and your mileage will vary widely
depending on the platform you play it on
so we scattered the internet to round up
the best bugs and glitches that players
encounter during their time in night
City fair warning some of these clips
were captured before more recent patches
to the game so they might have been
fixed by now for more cyber Punk make
sure to like this video And subscribe
let's check in and see those bugs and
glitches don't don't do it kiss my dad's
bunk
how much stuff is in there kiss my dead
spk I I
know what my what a sweet little face
you
have
no no ma'am ma'am no don't do that wait
where are you going to put that don't
you can't you can't jeez it's my Dead's
spnk what is
no hope enjoyed the
[Music]
fries be be honey did you see what
happened something feels off here you
don't
say this don't do
[Music]
this here all yours what So Good In
You
at least it's not GTA level of like you
you go in front of someone and they're
automatically trying to shoot you I
don't like the way he looked at
me
die bam save
[Laughter]
yourself
[Music]
I don't deserve this can't do
this
[Music]
I love you I love you
beep beep mother hey let's talk I'm not
going back hear me
never try to take me and I'll Crush you
you oh oh oh oh oh I fell through the
M Mercy I did nothing to
you no I don't want to
die
yo what the
it Courtney said it wasn't
buggy yo
officer hey I'm standing
[Laughter]
here are
you are
[Music]
you
City
milit protction for every boa will not
last
long shoot
him hold
[Music]
on
yo listen up I talked to Dex while you
were in with the dock he's waiting in
his ride for you ain't but a hop to
where he's parked next to gry Burgers
okay do my best to talk us
[Music]
up H how's it
going if you're armed place your weapon
here now please report to room number
two so what
now we've crossed the border now you pay
me and we go our separate
ways I ain't going to lie I'm a bit
light I can't pay you
now have something for you once I
collect my scrap for this corbal crap
we're carrying oh and you just figured I
would sit by pay actually I wasn't going
to pay you at all just going to bust ass
you're all
right yeah got my eye on you you're
welcome to Jurassic
Park
[Music]
w